The joe rogan experience.
And I also think that like reality at some point will always supersede nerf
padding.
You know,
there's always going to be a push back on that.
We go look like,
I don't want to offend anybody,
but you know,
and I do agree that there's a movement by the left that really does push,
you know,
I did a thing,
reason,
I'm doing this a charity event for uh,
like an urban program for kids.
Um,
mainly inner city black kids and I'm hosting it with my,
uh,
my buddy Mike Yard.
He's a really funny comic black dude and we went to meet with the guys for this
charity and they were telling us that,
uh,
you know,
were they have an auction and at any charity event,
right?
An auctioneer comes out and they all try to auction off and raise a lot of money
from rich people to help the program.
That's a very basically 99.9% of every charity event I've ever been involved.
This has an auction segment of the,
in the dinner they were like,
we're going to have that,
but we can't use the word auction.
I said,
what?
What do you mean you can't use the word auction?
They're like,
it's a sensitive word for you know the community.
And I was like,
and then yard goes,
are you talking about slavery?
Like his head almost exploded.
He was like,
wait,
we can't.
And I was like,
wait,
we can't say the word auction.
I'm like,
but aren't you hiring a guy from Southerby's?
Yeah,
his card's going to say auctioneer on it.
We're just going to pretend that's not what he's called.
And they were just like,
we just don't feel comfortable with that word in the room.
And I was just going to,
I can't see,
I said,
guys,
I gotta tell you it like you're making me want to vote for Trump.
That's what I said.
That's it.
That's how dumb I think this is.
I'm like all agree to it cause I want to help these kids.
But this is one of the dumbest things I've ever heard.
Wow.
I couldn't believe.
I was like,
can I say cotton?
Am I allowed to say like what other words can I say?
That's the dumbest thing I ever heard.
You're going to get triggered actions.
Auctions.
It's going to make a joke.
Like we're not going to joke around about like auctioning off a black person.
Although yard and I probably would have,
but first of all,
like when you say auction,
you automatically think of that boy,
it's not going to avoid taking a hold of this.
I'm going to want and want to.
Why do you think they did that with when they were doing that with slaves?
I do not think they talked like that.
I don't know what their technique was,
but I do know when I think of the word auction,
I'm not like,
Oh,
don't say that.
Don't say a word.
It's like it's an,
it's a new league.
It's absolutely accepted.
It's a different thing now.
Yeah.
It's like the word gay.
It's used to be Flinstones gay.
Have a okay time.
Having a gay time was like,
we're out having a good old time and then it became gay and then you had to stop
saying it that way,
but you can't just go back to gay happy like Flint.
So you can't,
but you can't.
For me growing up was the thing we just said about everything all the time.
Everything's good.
Doesn't matter.
Like the only thing you could,
you know it was,
it was terrible.
Did Gay go bad?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
It went bad after the f word went bad.
Did it?
Yeah,
effluent from,
was it connecting the two of them fucking gay and they're like,
whoa,
no,
not fucking.
I meant the word for gay people.
That to your body to say in fact that,
no,
I'm not afraid to,
but I'm just kind of being sarcastic when I say yes,
we're at the other f word.
It's like the other white meat.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like that was the,
and not that long.
And it was,
it was this idea of like if something was stupid,
it was gay,
it didn't mean homosexual.
It meant like Knob to don't be so gay,
but then you start thinking about,
oh I guess it does.
I guess it's offensive because you're saying like that stupid shirt you're
wearing is gay.
Of course it's that way.
But isn't it weird that gay took a turn for the worst?
Yeah.
Wouldn't you have loved to been at the intersection when gay went bad?
Like Pho,
we'll have a gay old time that's gay.
Yeah.
Whoa.
What are you saying?
Like an intersection of 36 came to me.
One overran it,
the mean one beat the happy gay.
It did.
Um,
gay took that.
They took the word gay and turns it into either a negative like,
oh that's gay or homosexuality.
Yep.
How was it not connected to homosexuality before?
I don't know.
I don't know if the connection came from the fact that like they're like,
oh those guys that gay shit,
like,
and they were like being like,
cause they were being like,
really?
You know how happy they were?
Like flamboyant boy.
Like,
well that guy's gay,
Huh?
He's really gay.
Like a gay is with that shiny shirt on,
you know,
hey that Liberace show her as gay.
And then maybe someone was like,
I'll show you gay and next thing you know people like,
hey,
we gotta,
we gotta stop.
We should stop with that word.
Come up with a new word gaze at different things.
Yeah.
Because I asked the guy to get gay with me and it got really,
really uncomfortable.
There had to be like a time in between where it was real confusing.
Right.
Where they didn't,
hadn't fully established what it meant yet,
where people were like,
hey man,
are you gay?
Yes,
I am gay.
I'm having a gale time guys like Goodman guy tackles him in the bushes.
Yup.
Like,
uh,
like the word hookup changed.
Yeah.
Like right around like when I was in high school,
but like my dad would be like,
hey,
are you going to hook up with your friends tonight?
You know what I mean?
And I'd be like,
what would it mean?
It means meet up with your friends.
I'm like,
that's not what it means.
You know,
like all my buddies would be in the room like,
hey,
you guys are going to hook up tonight with that.
I'm like,
don't touch it ever.
It was like,
dude,
your dad's gay.
Don't be so good.
That's hilarious.
So funny.
A lot of language shifts occur.
What it does feel like right now there's more policing of it and there's more
people act.
I Dunno,
there's just like,
there's a lot like the word pussy.
Yeah.
Is One of those where you can't say pussy anymore.
No.
People get offended by it.
I'm like,
cause he is like,
you're getting offended by the word,
but unless you're overusing it.
No,
no.
I'm saying again,
what I say or don't say is what I say or don't say it.
I take my licks if I have to,
but people get offended by it.
You know,
like that's a word now that like if you're,
you know,
if you're in like a hardcore leftist community,
you wouldn't say pussy,
but you'll still say dick guys being a deck.
It's like,
well that's offensive.
Those communities need a hug.
Yeah.
I feel like they don't need a hug.
Actually.
I feel like they need,
like I have too many hugs,
you know?
I think there's just too much.
I think it really,
it goes back to our lives are easy now,
so we have a lot of free time to come up with bullshit.
Yeah,
we do.
It's like if we had to actually,
we didn't have electricity or we didn't have like all this ease,
we wouldn't be,
you know,
harping on this stuff.
It's just like,
you have a lot of downtime,
a lot of downtime.
So you're like,
I'll start a blog.
I think I'll start blogging about words.
You shouldn't say it.
Okay.